[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 8 septembre
voici les titres
le procès des attentats du 13 novembre
2015 s'est ouvert aujourd'hui à paris 20
accusés 1800 partie civile pour la plus
grande audience criminelle jamais
organisée et qui va durer neuf mois dans
ce journal le témoignage d'un rescapé du
bataclan cette loi nous dira ce qu'il
attend de ce procès il est le seul site
yvelines on a retenu par nice en projet
le centre pédiatrique des côtes aux
loges en josas va bénéficier de l'aide
quatrième loto du patrimoine visite de
ce site du 19e siècle qui accueille des
enfants lourdement opéré sabine denis
sera également notre invité elle est
chargée de mission pour la délégation
ile de france de la fondation du
patrimoine
enfin après un été morose le soleil se
remontre en ce début du mois de
septembre des températures bien au delà
des normales de saison et les yvelinois
en profite avant le retour de la pluie
nous parlerons également de ce projet
d'envergure à saint quentin en yvelines
les abords de la gare sncf qui est
située à montigny le bretonneux elles
vont être profondément transformer dans
les prochaines années le détail tout à
l'heure dans cette édition
[Musique]
la france a donc rouvert l'une des pages
les plus douloureuse de son histoire le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
s'est ouvert aujourd'hui à paris 130
victimes et ont perdu la vie et des
centaines de blessés lors de ces
attaques perpétrées au bataclan au stade
de france et sur les terrasses de café
du 10ème et 11ème arrondissement de la
capitale le procès se déroule devant la
cour d'assises spéciale installée à
l'ancien palais de justice de paris une
salle i a été construite pour l'occasion
va individus sont accusés 14 seront
présents dont le seul terroriste encore
vivant et les six autres sont visés par
un mandat d'arrêt en face environ 1800
parties civiles dont 300 témoigneront au
cours des cinq prochaines semaines le
procès va durer neuf mois et 6 ans après
les faits les événements tragiques
survenus à paris et face à saint denis
vont être décortiqués pendant neuf mois
qu'attendent les familles des victimes
de ce procès est aussi les rescapés
écoutez le témoignage d'un l'illinois il
était au bataclan le soir du 13 novembre
2015 justin brasil a rencontré
130 morts 1800 parties civiles 20
accusés le procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 a débuté à paris ce 8
septembre à midi un procès attendu six
ans après les faits pour clore le volet
judiciaire de cette affaire mais aussi
redoutée il ya contexte un peu pesant ça
ça donc nos esprits la presse ne parle
que de cela je sais que les avocats des
parties civiles travaillent en
collaboration pour être efficace
pertinent et
je crois que le dossier qui a été
présenté à qui va être présenté à la
cour décide la cour d'assises spéciale
est plutôt béton trois attaques
perpétrés simultanément au bataclan au
stade de france et aux abords des
terrasses parisiennes thibault yvelinois
était venu assister au concert de rock
avec sa femme ce soir du 13 novembre
2015 il se souvient les fameux bruit de
pétard que beaucoup de personnes m'ont
rapporté
et donc je suis rattrapé mon épouse et
nous nous sommes allongées par terre
et un moment j'ai j'ai relevé la tête
pour ela sable et est allumée et j'ai vu
au niveau du par un homme un jeune homme
qui tirait sur les personnes qui étaient
au sol et c'est là que j'ai compris que
si on restait là on n'allait sans doute
pas on allait se faire tuer c'était
certain et si on essayait de partir ben
peut-être qu'on allait recevoir une
balle mais au moins j'aurai essayé
peut-être qu'on aura aussi la chance de
sortir de là à chaque fois que l'on
entend une détonation d'une arme ou une
rafale on se disait que la prochaine et
peut-être pour nous le couple arrive à
rejoindre les loges une jeune femme
creuserait alors un trou dans le faux
plafond d'un cabinet de toilette endroit
par où ils s'échapperont ils resteront
trois heures immobile dans les combles
avant d'être secouru par le raid le raid
nous prépare nous organiser pour sortir
et quitter le bataclan en envoyant moins
possible ce qui est voilà on sort en
file indienne en regardant par terre
mais la vision périphérique vous avez
fait qu'on capte quand même des
désinformations et c'est le chaos absolu
le chaos est total il ya du sens
absolument partout et des éclats de
balle il ya
c'est tout est cassé c'est tout est
dévasté c'est décors absolument partout
aujourd'hui thibault fait partie de
l'association 13 ans 15 qui soutient les
victimes du 13 novembre il s'est porté
partie civile pour le procès selon lui
on ne passe pas à autre chose mais il
faut avancer on passera jamais à autre
chose c'est déjà par respect pour les
personnes qui ne sont pas sortis de là
parce qu'il ya une culpabilité très très
forte nous on a eu la chance de sortir
de là sans être blessé sans perdre
approche mais il ya quand même 80 90
personnes qui sont mortes
au bataclan le procès devrait durer neuf
mois pour un verdict en mai 2022 une web
radio dédiée uniquement aux parties
civiles victimes ne pouvant être
présentes a été mise en place pour
suivre le procès à distance
et pour leurs 400 victimes des attentats
ont demandé l'accès à cette webradio
vivant le procès à distance elles auront
un accès à un accès à une assistance
psychologique dédié via un numéro
d'urgence est mise en place par deux
associations par y aide aux victimes et
france victime voilà ce qu'on pouvait
vous dire au sujet de cette actualité l
ouverture aujourd'hui de ce procès des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 il va a
duré neuf mois dans l'actualité locale
ce projet d'envergure en cours de
conception le promoteur immobilier codic
va réaménager les abords de la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines un projet à
partir de là nos rouge qui va être
totalement transformé en attendant
d'autres chantiers sont en cours de
finition est les détails de nicolas
landry sur des images de patrick jacques
de dixmude
voilà la future perspectives sur la gare
de saint quentin en yvelines depuis le
parc des sources de la bièvre un projet
mené par le promoteur immobilier codic
en collaboration avec les pouvoirs
publics une opération pour remplacer
l'anneau rouges datant des années 70 par
deux bâtiments au total ce seront 25
mille mètres carrés d'aménagement qui
devrait être construit l'idée c'est de
redonner depuis le parc des sources de
la bièvre une perspective sur la gare de
saint-quentin est amené deux immeubles
de part et d'autre avec les nouvelles
caractéristiques du bureau qu'on évoque
et sur lesquels on n'arrête pas
d'innover cette opération la suite de la
construction du bâtiment native un
chantier en cours dix neuf mille mètres
carrés d'espacé huit étages au total
pour une livraison prévue en mars 2022
aujourd'hui dans les travaux qui nous
reste à faire on a deux points de
vigilance important le premier c'est
mettre en place toute la technique qui
nous a été commandée par groupe orange
qui est une technique qui est à l'avant
garde de ce qui se pratique notamment en
termes de connectivité voilà donc des
technologies extrêmement poussée et puis
l'autre sujet qui est un peu en lien
avec la crise sanitaire qu'on est en
train de vivre des gens qu'elle en
extrêmement vigilant c'est toutes les
problématiques d'approvisionnement
puisque aujourd'hui on voit que sur un
certain nombre de chantiers les matières
premières manque le locataire de ce
bâtiment et l'opérateur orange les
premières équipes commenceront à arriver
en juin 2022 avec une installation
définitive en septembre 2022 au total
1200 collaborateurs travailleront ici ce
seront des chercheurs des techniciens du
réseau et également des équipes de
commercialisation les équipes peuvent
vont s'organiser sur des espaces avec
des espaces très collaboratif des
espaces de concentration des espaces de
détente des espaces de réunion le but
étant de travail et gérer en mode projet
ce type d'aménagement s'inscrit dans les
nouvelles organisations des espaces de
travail cette tendance devrait être
similaire dans le réaménagement de
l'hyper centre de saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
les journées du patrimoine sont
programmées le week-end des 18 et 19
septembre à quelques jours de cet
évènement la mission patrimoine confié à
stéphane bern a dévoilé les sites de
maillage retenu en 2021 dans le cadre du
loto loto du patrimoine et on en parle
avec mon invité sabine denis qui est
avec moi par visioconférence bonsoir
vous êtes chargé de mission pour la
délégation ile de france de la fondation
du patrimoine alors parmi elles les
projets sélectionnés incité est concerné
dans les yvelines c'est le centre
pédiatrique des côtes qui est située aux
loges en josas le lieu accueille dans un
bâtiment du xixème siècle des enfants
hospitalisés découverte de ce lieu avec
michael et demi d'euros c'est le sun
city vinoy retenu pour le loto du
patrimoine 2021 le centre pédiatrique
des coteaux loge en josas a été
sélectionné par les équipes de stéphane
bern la restauration concerne la toiture
du château construit dans la seconde
moitié du 19e siècle par la famille au
bercoff spécialisée dans la toile de
jouy nous avons constaté ces dernières
années des infiltrations d'eau très
importante au sein du château
dans les chambres dans les cuisines donc
quand on a fait venir des experts on
s'est rendu compte que l'ensemble du
toit et du zinc du toit devait être
changé on a quelques éléments comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi avec la
petite tourelle qui penche
dangereusement en danger pour les
résidents du site à l'intérieur du
château la structure accueille depuis
les années 50 du personnel de santé des
dizaines d'enfants ayant des maladies
cardiaques respiratoires et digestives
et défauts de la toiture ont des
conséquences sur les conditions
d'accueil on a des pans entiers de murs
et des chambres
qu'on peut aujourd'hui qu'on ne peut
plus utilisés aujourd'hui donc on ne
peut vraiment plus prendre en charge un
certain nombre de patients donc il
fallait véritablement
faire ces travaux de façon extrêmement
urgent le coût total de l'opération est
estimé à 600 mille euros sous réserve de
l'état de la charpente les travaux vont
débuter en janvier 2022
ce city vinoy fait donc partie de cette
nouvelle édition du loto du patrimoine
organisées par le ministère de la
culture la fondation du patrimoine et la
française des jeux sabine denis des
châteaux et départ ce loto du patrimoine
ce n'est pas étonnant mais voilà ces
édifices avec cette vocation là c'est
plutôt nouveau nom une un édifice qu'est
une vocation de santé oms précise que le
ce centre pédiatrique des côtes accueil
des enfants hospitalisés 1 / sur ce site
tout à fait c'est un peu une sélection
inédite dans les projets qui ont été
retenus cette année au titre des
maillages après ça répond tout à fait
aux critères de la mission berne qui
sont donc l'intérêt patrimonial qui est
ici caractérisée par l'histoire du site
qui est extrêmement lié à l'histoire de
la manufacture de la toile de jouy mais
l'état de péril on a eu des explications
dans votre reportage vraiment sur ces
sinistres qui impactent directement
l'activité du lieu mais aussi le projet
de valorisation l'attractivité d'un site
sur un territoire et son usage il faut
savoir aussi que ce site
est détenu par l'association de la
charité maternelle de paris qui est une
institution qui a été créée par marie
antoinette donc plusieurs éléments
historiques qui est des éléments aussi
vivant part par l'application du lieu
qu'ils sont qui sont à retenir et qui
ont été donc retenu dans le choix de ce
site on l'a compris avec une urgence à
agir pour que et bien ceux ci continuent
aussi à vivre et sa vocation actuelle à
accueillir ces enfants c'est est urgent
d'agir et de pouvoir lui venir en aide
oui tout à fait il ya une réelle
nécessité
puisque c'est un c'est un lieu qui est
forcément
[Musique]
mis aux normes tous tous les contrôler
tous les quatre ans et donc il y avait
un impact réel sur sur sur l'activité de
ce qu est l'accueil des enfants
qui sont sur ce site des nourrissons
jusqu'à
14 ans à peu près qui viennent pour un
temps court ou encore un peu plus long
retrouvez les forces et se soigner un
château qui datent du 19e siècle et vous
avez évoqué son histoire qui est lié à
la famille oberkampf juste à côté à jouy
en josas il ya cette panne une
manufacture de la toile de jouy qui a
été écrit la famille oberkampf en est à
l'origine
oui tout à fait et c'est cette famille
qui a donné le site en 1951 donc à
l'association qui gère la fondation qui
gère aujourd'hui donc se sentent
pédiatrique qui accueillent ces enfants
vous avez parlé de la sélection de ce
site et critères qui ont été retenues
pour le choix de ce site spécifique
comment sont ils sélectionnés justement
ces sites comment se fait cette
sélection
alors les projets sont déposés par
par les propriétaires que ce soit des
fondations des associations des communes
des particuliers sur le site de la
mission berne puis ensuite ils sont
examinés
par les par les 60 77 salariés et plus
de 600 sang bénévoles de la fondation du
patrimoine qui donne un avis un niveau
local puis il ya un comité où sont
présents donc stéphane bern des
représentants du ministère de la culture
de la fondation du patrimoine et de la
française des jeux qui ait statué donc
sur cette sélection pour retenir ces
sites au sein de ce loto du patrimoine
qui est donc proposée depuis le 30 août
avec des tickets à gratter qui sont
disponibles comment ça se passe
concrètement et finalement comment les
montants ensuite son sont sont reversés
pour pour idc site commentcamarche
alors les fonds sont donc issus du loto
du patrimoine donc vous avez là
plusieurs tirages qui ont lieu avant les
avant les journées du patrimoine
il y en a un ce soir notamment vous avez
les tickets à gratter et sur sur ses
tics et donc est sûre
les tirages donc il ya une part qui est
reversé donc
assez à ces projets la sélection est
annoncée
pour les projets le maillage donc à la
fin de l'été et montants sont connus à
la fin du dernier g dernier trimestre
de l'année de la sélection donc c'est la
quatrième édition du loto du patrimoine
627 sites ont été sélectionnés pour ces
quatre éditions combien ont pu être
sauvées grâce au loto du patrimoine
alors aujourd'hui on à 297 chantiers qui
sont eux qui sont en cours ou qui sont
terminées
et dans les yvelines
on a notamment
un chantier qui s'est terminé qu'est le
château 10 ou à côté de mantes la jolie
un chantier qui est qui est en cours qui
est donc la ville avoir de la ville à
vire doha où vival et à des travaux qui
vont bientôt commencer au centre voilà
pour ce d'affrètement de conflans sainte
honorine oui tu as plusieurs sites vous
le dites on était bien sélectionner déjà
par ce loto du patrimoine dans les yeux
vous ai cité la villa biardeau le
château dise où on peut citer également
l'orangerie du château d'anne au cours à
gargenville alors c'est une saison à
peine entamée on pense déjà à la
prochaine avec cette 5e édition du loto
l'appel à projets est ouvert jusqu'au 30
novembre pour les les sites
emblématiques jusqu'au 28 février 2022
pour les sites de maillage qui peut
candidater pour quel projet et comment
le faire finalement
c'est simple c'est qu'il faut donc vos
projets
correspondent aux critères que j'ai
énoncé précédemment qu'il ya un intérêt
patrimonial qui a une dimension de
péreille qu'ils soient qui soit forte et
que le projet soit vraiment ancré sur
son sur son territoire après rien de
plus simple il suffit de se rendre sur
le site de la mission berne et de
déposer le dossier qui est ensuite du
coût sera instruit par par là par la
fondation du patrimoine dans un premier
temps vous avez vous l'édition donc 2022
jusqu'au 30 novembre pour pouvoir
déposer des dossiers pour pouvoir
éventuellement être retenu comme le
projet emblématique de la région ile de
france ou bien jusqu'au 28 février 2022
pour pouvoir être sélectionné au titre
de maillage c'est-à-dire un projet par
département qui est retenu pensent-ils
de celui qui est qui est à souligner au
niveau régional un dernier mois avant de
vous laisser on revient à ce centre
pédiatrique des coteaux loges en josas
qui a été sélectionné et qui sera ouvert
aussi pour les journées du patrimoine on
pourra découvrir ce lieu qu'on vous a
fait découvrir un reportage ne pourra se
se rendre sur place oui tout à fait donc
vous pourrez vous y attendre le samedi
et le dimanche des journées du
patrimoine de 14 heures à 16 heures et
donc il y aura des visites qui vous
seront proposés pour découvrir ce lieu
insolite merci ça vient de nier pour
toutes ces précisions
merci à vous et je rappelle que vous
êtes chargé de mission à la délégation
ile-de-france pour la fondation du
patrimoine
[Musique]
pour le retour du trophée sport passion
pour une 28e édition de nombreuses
personnalités se sont donné rendez-vous
au golf de bêtement à poissy pour une
compétition de golf sous le signe de la
bonne humeur on va peut-être pouvoir
voir les images s'affichent et dans un
instant il y avait notamment sur place
l'ancien patineur philippe candeloro qui
est le parrain de ce trophée cette année
un événement sur lequel télé 78
reviendra dans le premier numéro du 7-8
sports lundi prochain donc ce sera sur
tv 78 et s'est présentée par michael et
me d'euros et du handball féminin le
club du paris 92 dont tv 78 et
partenaires a présenté cette semaine son
effectif pour la nouvelle saison une
équipe qui comptera dans ses rangs l'une
des championnes olympiques à tokyo laura
flippes le reportage de michael oenning
une nouvelle saison débute pour les
lionnes du paris 92 l'effectif désormais
au complet été officiellement présentée
à l'aube du premier match il aura pour
objectif de finir sur le podium après
avoir terminé dans le top-5 l'année
dernière les ambitions monde d'année en
année là elles sont de plus en plus
forte
on va maintenant commencer à aviser
avisés des titres tous les ans peut-être
pas forcément cette année mais en tout
cas on s'y prépare dans son effectif le
club pourra compter sur sa capitaine
yvelinoise deborah la source à 21 ans la
handballeuse originaire de maisons
laffitte est au club depuis sept ans
paris 92 comptera également dans ses
rangs une championne olympique en titre
avec laura flippes l'une des meilleures
joueuses françaises à tokyo cet été
j'ai envie de faire une belle saison
j'ai envie d'aider l'équipe au maximum
et qu'on fasse de bons résultats cette
saison je pense que ça change beaucoup
pour elle mais c'est vrai que pour nous
on est très fier très contente pour elle
mais ça reste une aventure de sélection
et non en club donc on espère justement
gagner des titres avec elle au total le
club pourra compter sur quatorze
joueuses professionnelles et des jeunes
du centre de formation un effectif plus
étoffé que les dernières années ça me
permet de pouvoir amener certaines
josette fraîche dans les moments
importants du match ça me permet
également de diversifier les formes de
jeu
donc effectivement pour un coach c'est
très intéressant d'avoir autant
d'options premier match ce mercredi 8
septembre pour les lionnes contre
chambre et la rencontre est programmée à
20h au palais des sports d'issy les
moulineaux
et puis on lie était en juillet en août
l'été semble vouloir se déporter de
quelques semaines dans les yvelines des
records de chaleur ont été enregistrés
ces derniers jours avec des températures
de 8 degrés au dessus des normales de
saison l'occasion pour les yvelinois est
de profiter encore un peu des beaux
jours céline charles
un soleil de plomb de fortes chaleurs
malgré la rentrée il flotte comme un air
de vacances partout où l'on se promène
au marché de versailles les habitants
affluaient à nouveau entre les étals de
quoi ravir les marchands
formidable
non votants c'est le week-end
sauf dimanche
pourtant il semble que le travail ne
soit pas la priorité de tous jogging
vélo ou encore badminton entre collègues
c'est avec plus de 30 degrés que ces
sportifs rattrapant n'étaient plus que
maussade de 30 septembre est de
retrouver le beau temps comme ça ça fait
vraiment plaisir et puis c'est un moment
convivial parce qu'on est tous ensemble
ici on profite du du parc du soleil de
jogging
moral je suis à tout supporter ce qu'il
faut c'est super sympa parce que ça
donne du baume au coeur ça permet aux
gens de retourner
dans un espace de travail b avec
le soleil la chaleur et la beauté des
paysages et en même temps il fait très
très chaud on ne sait pas c'est pas
évident pour tout le monde des
températures supérieures aux normales de
saison de cet avis degré un bain de
soleil qui fait du bien aux travailleurs
et aux étudiants ça fait du bien on peut
prendre des heures entérale c'est enfin
en profite voilà après tout ce mauvais
temps dépit mais qui arrive peut-être un
peu trop tard tous les gens travaillent
maintenant une reprise on n'a pas
profité des vacances on n'a pas eu le
temps et du coup forcément les vacances
au vert on crache pas dans la soupe ça
fait du bien ces chaises vides attendons
preneur avant le retour du mauvais temps
qui devrait à nouveau pointé le bout de
son nez en fin de semaine
puisque mauvaise nouvelle le mauvais
temps va vite revenir les yvelines ont
été placés ce soir par météo france en
vigilance orange aux orages comme 31 et
départements de l'hexagone l alerte
cours de ce soir mercredi à 20h et
jusqu'à 1h du matin dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi des pluies intenses ont
prévu à voir même de la grêle et de
fortes rafales de vent prudence donc ce
soir
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]